day-to-day getting better every single
day
um asking questions aligning yourself
with people that have been through it
before that are
um that are experienced and leaning on
that advice and uh just trying to
outwork the next person and that's the
biggest thing
well for me I mean yeah you visualize
where you want to be and what you want
to accomplish and
you kind of get lost in the process of
day-to-day you know grinding it out and
working
pulling on ours if you have to
um you know that this is just about
not losing vision and not losing sight
of what you're what you're trying to
accomplish no matter what hurdles you
have to go through so
um I think that
kind of relates to whatever you're doing
uh whatever
um
you know major you've chosen or what
you're interested in so for me in
basketball and it's about you know
visualizing whether you write it down
put it on the wall do something what
what your goals are um and get lost in
the process of day-to-day grind you just
want to be the hardest worker guy no
matter what you do in life we're all
talented in some way shape or form and
have a passion so once you find out what
that is
um I'm just exhaust all efforts to
better yourself every day in that regard
so that's what drives me um
it's a confidence that's built on the
foundation of work and the Reps I put in
time you put in the gym all the
different stuff that I do to get ready
for games so I don't just come out
thinking I'm gonna just make everything
without having you know seeing all those
practice shots go in so
um you know and I have fun doing what I
do that's that's what uh I enjoy most
about playing basketball for a living we
enjoy what we do we have fun doing it we
show it and I think that's why we've
been so successful and hopefully
continue so just to keep my confidence
keep my aggressiveness I prepared well
to this summer to continue to get better
and learn from those mistakes I'll call
them they're gonna happen there's no
avoiding that but just making sure that
it doesn't kill your confidence and it
doesn't change the way you're playing be
you be obsessed in the things that you
can control and that's
like all the intangibles of being a
great leader great teammate
uh consistent effort every every night
finding ways to be your best even on the
days
no matter how you know great people tell
you you are or
credit how you know lucky or
inadequate critics say you are you know
whatever whatever drives you inside
whatever you find that you know that
will to keep going is
is about not being complacent and always
trying to get better no matter how hard
that mission might be it's yourself and
you really have to find what it is that
motivates you and hold on to that
um every single day and that's something
I'm very proud of and very you know
appreciative of of the people that
helped me get to this place so
I've tried to surround myself with
people that push me that motivate me
that keep me focused to keep me you know
focused on the right things in this life
I have that on the stage right here I
have that my family and for that I'm
extremely blessed and extremely thankful
for that because this is a crazy world
and to have that kind of guidance and
that kind of motivation definitely has
allowed me to do what I do on and off
the court so
aligning myself with the right people uh
around me
um there are good positive influences
and and for me
um obviously trying to you know to read
every single day
um you know holding it on on what my
focus is supposed to be and what my
purpose is in life there's more there's
more to life than basketball there's
obviously the most important thing is
your family and taking care of each
other loving each other no matter what
and I and regardless if I were to play
basketball or not I know you guys love
me with that shadow of a doubt you would
have encouraged me in any
part of life that or any path that I
take or what I've taken so you realize
that all the hard work that you put into
it was worth it it just made me realize
how blessed and grateful I really am to
be in this position
um on this platform to be able to impact
so many people across the world by just
you know trying to be myself I'm the son
of a 16-year NBA veteran
um I remember a lot of his career I was
blessed to have a family that we never
really struggled when I was growing up
thanks to my dad and his career
um you know we had the means to do a lot
growing up but
you would think that my future was set
based on that fact and that couldn't be
farther from the truth
um I was always the smallest kid of my
my team when it comes to basketball I
was always the smallest kid on my team
I had a terrible ugly catapult shot from
uh time I was 14 because I wasn't strong
enough to shoot over my head and I had
to reconstruct that over a summer and it
was the worst three months of my life
you think there were no hurdles or
obstacles that I had overcome but
even when I got to high school I wasn't
ranked that wasn't highly touted as a
high school Prospect I had nobody really
running knocking on my door saying
please please please come play for our
school and you know everything happens
for a reason and there's there's a story
into everything and and if you take time
to realize you know what what your dream
is
and and what you really want in life no
matter what it is whether it's Sports
whether it's in other fields
um
you have to realize that there's always
work to do and you want to be the
hardest working person in whatever you
do and you put yourself in position to
be successful
um and you have to have a passion about
what you do and basketball was mine and
that's what scared me to this point when
you play against greatness and you play
against people that push you
or have what you have before and you're
chasing
um you almost get consumed by it because
one how hard it is obviously to reach
the top and the amount of work that you
put into it you always try to find that
little bit of edge whether it's
something mental or something physical
that you can use see advantage to to
kind of stay on the heels until you get
there no matter what happens in life I
try to stay as even Keel as possible
knowing everything is a blessing I want
to bring something to the table and from
a leadership perspective but again
you're only as good as people are around
you you be able to grow together and go
through different experiences I know
what I'm capable of and what I can bring
to the table but nothing that you do in
life you do alone and have an
appreciation for the value in others I
can learn something from the person next
to me and my right of my left they can
challenge me the sense of accountability
it's how you grow and for me that's
where you really make memories in terms
of I could do all this stuff about
myself if I have nobody to share it with
and nobody to kind of go back and say
hey look what we did I don't think
there's any value in that my faith
allows me to stay focused on why I'm on
this planet to begin with because if I
were to listen to the noise and to
continually feed into what is rewarded
in this life on Earth material for
things or whatever
fame money all that type of stuff like I
would be lost no burdens too it's too
tall too heavy yeah and so for me every
day every day is a challenge continually
to stay focused on things get being fed
with the right things staying in the
word I mean the Genesis of pretty much
anything I do is to try to inspire and
finding different ways to to reach the
masses to use a platform that I have to
kind of you know share the the core
values of who I am as a person they
stayed in the moment and just focused on
here and now and part of that is having
the will to succeed
um
and you're knowing that you put the work
in and have the confidence to let it
show
um what I tell people is just be the
best version of yourself in anything
that you do
you don't have to live anybody else's
story
sometimes people make it seem like you
have to have certain prerequisites or a
crazy life story in order to be
successful in this world but the truth
is you really don't it doesn't matter
where you come from
what you have or don't have
what you lack what you have too much of
but all you need to have is faith in God
an undying passion for what you do
and what you choose to do in this life
in a Relentless drive and the will to do
whatever it takes to be successful and
whatever you put your mind to
make sure you live in the moment
and work your butt off every single day
and I hope I inspire people all around
the world to just be themselves be
humble and be grateful for all the
blessings in your life
[Music]